ich bin immer total begeistert von
irgendwelchen Produkten die nicht kommen
Mensch braucht sondern die ja kompletter
Schrott sein und jetzt habe ich aber ein
Produkt gefunden das wollte ja zuerstall
Lächerlichkeit preisgeben hier in der
Sendung aber noch wie es ausprobiert und
ich war total begeistert davon ein
weinglashalter für die Dusche wir oft
haben sie sich beim Duschen so denkt
sehr fixe das simuliert jetzt die
Duschwand das ganze und da ist da vorne
der weinglashalter und er zu verfassen
auf immer wenn sie beim Duschen wenn sie
dort oder der Durst übermannt nehmen
das Wasser läuft es wäre nicht leer
das ist sozusagen der umgekehrte Jesus
Effekt sie machen Wein zu Wasser